we'll hear arguments number 18 roll
against wait this is ready you may
proceed whenever you're ready
mr. Chief Justice and may it please the
court the instant case is a direct
appeal from a decision of the United
States District Court for the Northern
District of Texas the court declared the
Texas abortion law will be
unconstitutional for two reasons first
as the law was impermissibly vague and
second that it violated a woman's right
to determine to continue or terminate a
pregnancy although the court granted
declaratory relief the court denied
appellant request for injunctive relief
the Texas law in question permits
abortions to be performed only in
instances where is for the purpose of
saving the life of the woman the case
originated with the filing of two
separate complaints the first being
filed on behalf of Jane row an unmarried
pregnant girl and the second being filed
on behalf of Jane and Mary Doe a married
couple
Jane row the pregnant woman had gone to
several Dallas physician seeking an
abortion but had been refused care
because of the Texas law she filed suit
on behalf of herself and all those women
who have in the past at that present
time or in the future would seek
termination of a pregnancy in her after
day that she did say some of the reasons
that she desired an abortion at the time
she sought one but contrary to the
contentions of appellees she continued
to desire the abortion and it was not
only at the
she saw the abortion that her desire was
to terminate the pregnancy when this
case was in the district court the case
of buuck against the United States had
not been decided yet I do you think that
has disposed of some of the questions
raised now Your Honor I do not and the
voyage decision this court was working
with the statute which provided that an
abortion could be performed for reasons
of health or lives our Texas statute
provides an abortion only where it isn't
where it is for the purpose of saving
the life of the woman since the voyage
decision was rendered the Texas Court of
Criminal Appeals which is our highest
court of criminal jurisdiction has held
that the Texas law is not based citing
The Verge decision but saying that the
Texas law is more definite than the DC
law so obviously the Court of Criminal
Appeals doesn't feel that the two of the
same and in the Bhoots decisions the
justices of this Court emphasized
continuously but a doctor as a matter of
routine works with the problem of what
is best for the help of his patients we
submit that a doctor is not used to
being restricted to acting only when it
for the purpose of saving the life of
the woman and that health is a continuum
which runs into life and a doctor in our
state does not know whether he can
perform an abortion only when when death
is imminent or when the woman's life
would be shortened he does not know if
the death must be certain or if it could
be an increase in probability of her
death so here in the district doctors
are able to exercise their normal matter
of judgment whether or not the help of a
woman mental or physical would be
affected but in Texas we tell a doctor
that unless he can decide whether it's
necessary for the purpose of saving her
life and for no other reason that he is
subject to criminal sanction
I think it's important to know the range
of problems that could be presented to a
doctor the court for example cited the
incidence of suicide if a woman comes in
alleging that she will commit suicide if
it's in necessary for him to do or can
you do an abortion for the purpose of
saving her life or is that a situation
where he has to have something more I
think all of those questions cannot be
answered at this point this brings up
the married couple in our case the woman
in that case had a neurochemical
condition her doctor had advised her not
to get pregnant and not to take the
birth control pill she was using
alternative means of birth control but
she and her husband were fearful that
she would become pregnant and that
although the neurochemical conditions
would impair her health there was
evidently her doctor did not feel that
she would die if she continued the
pregnancy and certainly they were very
concerned about the effect of the
statute and her physician seemed
uncertain about its implications
the doctors in our state continue to
feel that our law is made certainly we
introduced affidavits in the lower court
today at best since the time of the
lower court ruling the district attorney
in Texas has said that he will that he
considers the federal court decision
they are not to be binding and he is and
we do have a letter from him and the
first thing in our appendix to the brief
stating that he will continue to
prosecute so the doctors in Texas even
with the federal decision and even after
the village decision do not feel free to
perform abortions and instead 728 women
in the first nine months after the
decision went to New York for abortion
Texas women are coming here it's so
often the poor and the disadvantaged in
Texas who are not able to escape the
effect of the law certainly there are
many Texas women who are affected
because our doctors
still feel uncertain about the impact of
the law even in light of the rich
decision a little courtship wedington
you make many additional constitutional
attack upon the Texas statute and only
one was before us in the audience your
honor willingly only the claim of
unconstitutional vagueness the court
explicitly didn't read it in any other
claim did you make many other claims and
of course before you get to any of those
there is a many threshold question
whether or not oh yes your honor their
honor I think it's of course important
to point out to the court that in my
reading of younger versus Harrison the
companion cases all the court was
concerned about in those cases was a
situation where there was an attempt to
interfere with the pending state
criminal prosecution in this case as I
pointed out the original parties to this
matter are women and in one case the
husband the women certainly are not
subject to prosecution in the state of
Texas they are it is impossible for them
to stand in the criminal dock and
litigate their interest they came
seeking injunctive relief but it was not
against pending state criminal
prosecutions they were not even aware of
the prosecution against dr. Hoffler
today today under Texas law being
charged as accomplices or your honor
conspirators or anything like now we
have expressed Texas cases in one
situation would Roe versus state in 1882
the woman had taken a potion to induce
abortion and the Texas Court
specifically said that the moment you
coz of no crime even in that situation
and that in fact she is the victim of
our law she kept there is no declaratory
relief available for these plaintiffs
their only forum with the federal court
and it was to those courts that they
turn your three plaintiffs here
learning classes I gather with one Amon
nice pregnant woman a married couple yes
and the dark green diamond would be
injurious to the wife's health to have a
child and also enjoy to her health to
use the most efficient form of birth
control and then third as a physician
yes a little under indictment a lot of
the time is the fifth physician
intervened after the order was entered
granting janroe a three-judge court and
he intervened again asking only that
future prosecution under the law be
enjoined he did not ask any relief of
the court relating to his pending state
criminal prosecution he did specifically
in his complaint reserve the right to
act for future release but that was
never done and certainly in the future
if he were asked for relief the court
would have the guidance of the younger
versus Harris companion cases but there
was in no way any request for any action
to interfere with the pending criminal
prosecutions then in process
as to there is an allegation that the
question is moved since the woman has
now had has carried the pregnancy to
term and I think it isn't it is
important to realize that there are
several important aspects in which this
case differs from the case that the
court might usually be presented first
the case is different in the nature of
the interest which is involved and in
the extent to which personal
determination is undermined by this
statute the effect that it has on women
second it is unique in the type of
injury that's presented certainly there
are some injuries that can be
compensated and most left over a
sufficient period of time for the courts
to litigate the interest but in this
case of progressing pregnancy does not
suspend itself in order to give the time
the court's time to add certainly Jane
Roe brought her suit as soon as she knew
she was pregnant as soon as she had
sought an abortion and been denied she
came to federal court she came on behalf
of a class of women and I don't think
there's any question that women in Texas
continued to devour abortion and to seek
them out outside our state there was an
absence of any other remedy and without
the ability to list litigate her claim
as a pregnant woman who came seeking
relief and who assumed was affected by
the time required for the federal
process not B not because of any
infirmity in her own attempts to
litigate her interest that this will in
fact to be a case certainly presenting
substantial federal question and yet
evading review in the future
I think the third way in which it is
unique is as I stated the fact that it
is the only forum available to these
women they have no other way to litigate
their interest doesn't mean that there
is no possibility of getting a
declaratory judgment under Texas law yes
your honor declaratory judgment in the
state of Texas are limited to a
situation where property rights are
involved and we also have a very unusual
situation in Texas where we have two
concurrent jurisdictions one the civil
and one the criminal and even there are
some cases which indicates that our
state Supreme Court would not have the
ability to mandamus any of the criminal
prosecution officers because the Texas
Court of Criminal Appeals has
jurisdiction as to all criminal matters
in the state of Texas so even if the
Romans had been able to bring a
declaratory judgment which he couldn't
she couldn't have gotten any sort of
relief against future prosecution and it
was exactly the absence of the court
granting an injunction against future
prosecutions which have resulted in the
irreparable injury these women had
suffered in Texas the woman is the
victim the state cannot deny the effect
that this law has on the women of Texas
certainly there are problems regarding
even the use of contraception of
abortion now for a woman it's safer than
childbirth in the absence of abortions
are legal medically safe abortions women
often result to the illegal abortion
which certainly carry risks of death all
the side effects such as severe
infection permanence to realities all
the consultations that result and in
fact if the woman is unable to get
either illegal abortion or an illegal
abortion in our state she can do a self
abortion which is certainly perhaps by
far the most dangerous and that is no
crime she is in our states
Oh microphone most effective thank you
Texas for example because it appears to
us would not allow any relief at all
even in situations where the mother
would suffer perhaps serious physical or
mental harm there's certainly a great
question about it if the pregnancy would
result in the birth of a deformed affect
this child she has no relief regardless
of the circumstances of conception
whether it was because of rape incest
whether she is extremely immature she
has no relief
I think it's without question that
pregnancy to a woman can completely
disrupt her lives whether she's
unmarried whether she's in pursuing an
education whether she's pursuing a
career whether she had family problems
all of the problems of personal and
family life for a woman are bound up in
the problem of abortion for example in
our state there are many schools where a
woman is forced to quit if she becomes
pregnant in the City of Austin that is
true a woman if she becomes pregnant and
is in high school must resign or must
drop out of regular education regular
education process and that's true of
some colleges in our state in the matter
of employment she often is forced to
quit at an early point in her pregnancy
she has no provision for maternity leave
she has she cannot get unemployment
compensation under our laws because the
law holds that she is not eligible for
employment being pregnant and therefore
is eligible for no unemployment
compensation at the same time she can
get no welfare to help her at a time
when she has no unemployment
compensation and she's not eligible for
any health and getting a job to provide
for herself there is no duty for
employers to rehire women if they must
drop out to carry a pregnancy to term
and of course this is especially hard on
the many women
in Texas who are heads of their own
household and must provide for their
already existing children and obviously
the responsibility of raising a child is
the most serious one and the time and
emotional investment that must be made
cannot be denied so a pregnancy to a
woman is perhaps one of the most
determinate 'iv aspects of her lives it
disrupts her her body it disrupts her
education it disrupts for employment and
it often disrupts her entire family life
and we feel that because of the impact
on the woman this certainly and as far
as there are any rights which are
fundamental is a matter which is of such
fundamental and basic concern to the
woman involved that she should be
allowed to make the choice as to whether
to continue or to terminate for
pregnancy
think the question is equally serious
for the positions of our state they are
seeking to practice medicine and what
they consider the highest method of
practice we have affidavits in the back
of our brief from each of the heads of
public of heads of obstetrics and
gynecology departments from each of our
public medical schools in Texas and each
of them points out that they were
willing and interested to immediately
begin to formulate methods of providing
care and services for women who are
pregnant and who do not desire to
continue the pregnancy they were stopped
cold in their efforts even with the
declaratory judgment because of the DA's
position that they would continue to
prosecute ready to move so far on the
marriage
told us about the important impact of
this law and it's made a very eloquent
policy argument against it
I trust you are going to get to what
provisions of the Constitution you rely
on because of course with Bernie we like
you sometimes we come out here busy
involved simply reminders at all your
honor in the lower court as I'm sure
you're aware the court held as the right
to determine whether or not to continue
a pregnancy rested upon the ninth
amendment which of course reserves those
rights not specifically enumerated to
the government to the people I think it
is important to note in a larger article
recently submitted to the court and of
distributed among council by professor
fearo means jr. entitled the Phoenix of
abortion of freedom that at the time the
Constitution was adopted there was no
common law prohibition against abortion
that they were available to the women of
this country certainly under the
Griswold decision it appears that the
members of the court in that case were
obviously divided as to the specific
constitutional framework of the right
which they held to exist in the Griswold
decision I'm a little reluctant to
aspire to a wisdom that the court is not
was not in agreement on I do feel that
it is that the ninth amendment is an
appropriate place for the freedom to
risk
I think the 14th amendment is equally an
appropriate place under the rights of
persons to life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness I think and as far as
Liberty is meaningful but Liberty to
these women would mean Liberty from
being forced to continue the unwanted
pregnancy relying in this branch of your
argument simply on the Due Process
Clause of the 14th amendment we had
originally brought the suit alleging
both the due process clause the equal
protection clause the Ninth Amendment
and a variety of other senators oh yeah
I think you helped since the district
court found the right to reside in the
ninth amendment we pointed our attention
in the brief to that particular aspect
of the Constitution but I think we would
not presume I I do feel that that in so
much as members of the court had said
the Ninth Amendment applies to rights
reserved to the people and those which
were most important and certainly this
is that the ninth amendment is
appropriate place insofar as the court
has says it that life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness involves a very
most fundamental thing of people that
this matter is one of those most
fundamental matters I think in as far as
the court has said if there is a
penumbra that exists to encompass the
entire purpose of the Constitution that
I think one of the purposes of the
Constitution was to guarantee to the
individual the right to determine the
course of their own lives insofar as
there was perhaps no compelling state
interest and realized there is none in
this case but there again the right fits
within the framework of the previous
decisions of this Court
what is the asserted state interest does
the is there any legislative history
about this country no sir your honor no
sir there is not
the only legislative history of course
is that which is found in other states
which has been pointed out to the court
before and professor mean points out
again that these statutes were adopted
for the health of the mother certainly
the Texas courts have referred to the
woman as being the victim and they have
never referred to any
else as being the victim time to have
certainly changed I think it's important
to to realize that in Texas self
abortion is no crime
the woman is guilty of no crime even
though she seeks out the doctor even
though she consents even though she
participates even though she pays for
the procedure she again is guilty of no
crime whatsoever it's also interesting
that our statute the penalty for the
offense of abortion depends on whether
or not the consent of the woman was
obtained prior to the procedure it's
double if you don't get her consent
there is no indication in Fondren birth
the state for example the court ruled
that a woman who commits an abortion on
herself is guilty of no crime again she
being regarded as a victim rather than
the perpetrator of the crime obviously
it's in our state the offense is not
murder it is an abortion which carries a
significantly lesser offense there is no
requirement of even though the state in
its brief points out the development of
the fetus and eight-week period the same
state does not require any death
certificate or any formalities of birth
that the product of such a conception
would be handled merely as a
pathological specimen and the statute
doesn't make any distinction based upon
what period of pregnancy in the abortion
history no your honor
there is no time limit or indication of
time whatsoever so I think well do you
make any distinction no sir I do I feel
that the question of a time limit is not
strictly before the court because of the
nature of of a situation in which the
case is handled certainly I think as a
practical matter though most of the
states that do have some time limit
indicated Silph remit abortions beyond
the time limit for specified reasons
usually again where the health of the
mother is what also puts your
constitutional position
as to a time and what about whatever
cause the Constitution you rest on Ninth
Amendment due process the general
pattern the number it is our limit let's
take you right up to the time of birth
it is our position that the freedom
involved is that of a woman to determine
whether or not to continue a pregnancy
obviously I have a much more difficult
time saying that the state has no
interest in late pregnancy environment I
think it's more the emotional response
to a lake pregnancy rather than it is
any constitutional I guess by persons
considering the issue outside the legal
context I think it's hard to say don't
you say this is how would they insist on
reaches the time of third time the
Constitution as I read it and it's
interrupted and documented by Professor
me attaches protection to the person at
the time of birth those persons born our
citizens the enumeration clause we count
those people who are born the
Constitution as I see it gives
protections to people after birth
this wedding tonight we leave you here I
guess
on your field whether your untidily
jump easily yes sir
assuming this and all other respects so
you arguing for a second why do you
think in addition to the cleric early to
entitle to impossibly significant things
yes sir certainly in your descent you
point out in Perez versus or that's not
incurring the same opinions your
physical it was a defense thing that
there are different standards which
apply to the declaratory judgment and to
injunctive relief yes that's correct
and that's what the court said
followings whittler versus kuta that
even though they were granting
declaratory declaratory relief it's
different considerations apply to
injunctive relief but it seems that the
opinions of this Court has established
that where there is a raffles there is
great and immediate threat of
irreparable injury with no adequate
remedy in state court that an injunction
is still progress and it is our position
that there is great and immediate threat
of irreparable injury in the form of a
continuing pregnancy that will not abate
and that continues for years you're
really here says you're asserting that
the the pregnant woman has standing okay
and the very couple where the wife is
not significantly
I was what about the doctor of we're
very criminal application was already
pending against the doctor as I said was
asking no relief as to the pending
prosecution he was only asking relief as
to future prosecution for the burgers
yes your honor he joined in both the
request for the declaratory judgment max
Allen with where they were pending where
the Samuel vs. Michael is I read it did
say that where you have and I request
for declaratory judgment there would be
in effect on a pending criminal
prosecution was her biggest there was
one pending when this action was brought
that one adults those against dr.
Hallford however in this case we submit
that if there is to be any meaning to
the federal court as the supreme
arbiters of constitutional rights that
they must be able to act at least in
some form when there are pending
criminal prosecutions not particularly
against the person involved in the
prosecution but other three circuit
courts may but there were limited
situations there is a corrector for the
prosecution
improperly is use a device to iraq of
the person practically forget it
yes your honor but again as I understood
it and you just get suggested other
people doesn't that I'm suggesting that
in this case these the women in
particular brought a declaratory action
has been nothing to do with the pending
state criminal prosecutors barking hose
and that the intervention of the doctor
certainly should not be sufficient or as
to the doctors three right that the the
intervention that because the doctor
intervenes when he was asking no report
no relief as to the pending state
criminal prosecutions that his
intervention he was actively he was
asking what no he wasn't against the
continuous to that folks that's correct
he's willing to litigate the earlier
judge as the future prosecution except
Lee one of the declaratory judgments on
the side with the underlying statute on
with the prosecution brought is
unconscious the man yes and what that's
what Sanders and myself it is pretty
fast
and what your defense said was incorrect
but I repeat it wasn't is that okay oh I
think perhaps we would stress that there
are two separate actions before the
court first out of the women and second
out of the doctor so that even though
even though the doctor even though the
court might find that the doctor was an
inappropriate party for relief it
certainly would not affect the original
action as brought by the women or animal
I come back again it if we're left only
with it or the ladies night you're
suggesting with the
territorially they already obtained is
not enough because that doesn't help
terminate the figure because they are
still subject to the irreparable injury
and had no adequate state remedy and if
if they are not able to continue to
litigate their interest in this
situation anytime there was any
prosecutions pending against anyone in
the state at any point in the appeal for
example the Thompson case was filed in
1968 it's been decided now in our say
courts upon appeal or it will be
appealed here I think and certainly if
they cannot litigate their interest
while there is prosecutions pending
against the doctor they will in many
instances where a statute where there
are supposed to every party against the
doctor is my finding any doctor stranger
available at it yes they cannot even
decide to take the risk for themselves
and the declaratory judgment Davis must
rely on another person to take that risk
but certainly the doctor raised not only
his own rights but the rights of his
patients and those same patients are
suffering the same sort of irreparable
injury that's the original plaintiffs
were suffering from the dr. Rey that
same voice and the criminal prosecution
yes your honor he can but I I don't feel
it's appropriate to make those women who
are most vitally effective certainly
more so than the doctor who can merely
decide not to perform an abortion and
thereby escape when he was a doctor you
said there were two separate issues with
the issue involved in the doctors
litigate everything is now litigated in
the state so yes your honor my point
being that that these women should not
be compelled to leave it up to a doctor
to litigate those and all of us if they
defend himself internal prosecution is
lead is not anything to do that well I
think there are different interests
involved and in most criminal
prosecutions the doctors would bring up
other problems such as I do others yeah
all right the witnesses have disappeared
or it really was for this reason is the
collocation but Doug has had this
defense ever been a deposed in a Texas
criminal case yes your honor there is
one recent opinion Thompson versus the
state of Texas which the Attorney
General attempted to bring to the
attention of the court and it was not
trended in the court rejected it it was
a decision about a month and a half ago
which originated in Houston a doctor
there was indicted on a charge of
abortion at trial he used only an alibi
defense but on his appeal he did raise
the same constitutional questions that
we raised in the federal court or any of
those roots no your honor they they
could have but they didn't they went
ahead and litigated those issues and our
Texas Court of Criminal Appeals which is
our highest court has now held that the
statute is not the Excite
village which again I would contend as
an incorrect reliance case decided to
the Chief Justice yes and second that
there that they specifically did not
determine whether or not there was a
right to privacy but did hold there was
a compelling interest so in that
particular situation which is the only
situation a doctor did attempt to
litigate the cemetery's Court of
Criminal Appeals has basically upheld
the constitutionality to recognize they
Excel really direct directly in
opposition to the federal court opinion
from which we are appealing
they have filed a motion for rehearing
in the state Court of Criminal Appeals
which will be argued tomorrow I think
it's very unlikely that the court would
change its opinion and it is the
intention of those parties to appeal how
does Texas law in other areas of the law
give rights to unborn children in the
areas of trusts and estates and will no
your honor only only if they are born
alive we have the Supreme Court of Texas
recently has held in one case that there
is an action for prenatal injuries at
any stage prior to birth but only upon
the condition that it be born alive the
same is true of our property law the
child must be born alive and I think
there is a distinction between those
children which are ultimately born and I
think it is appropriate to give them
retroactive ride but I think that's a
completely different question from
whether or not they had rights at the
time they were still in the room what
about the
who is as a result of an accident killed
or whatever we're doing to use there has
been no situation litigated like that in
Texas but suppose you noted that they
are around the country the Iowa Supreme
Court about two weeks ago held it where
it was stillborn there was no cause of
action whatsoever the child the mother
or the manoeuvres when I'm speaking
excuse me solely for the fetus that the
fetus had no independent right that the
month the mother mother recovering on or
these deaths of the time for the
whatever II would only for her injuries
were her he had I didn't lose anything
was regarded the time I do this is
running to this board
mr. Chief Justice it please the court
it's no joke when an argument Argos
against two beautiful ladies like this
they're going to have last word I before
I proceed to the original issue in this
case which was the propriety of the
trial court grant are denying injunctive
relief I would like to bring to the
court's attention some great matters
concerning what has been referred to as
the standing of the parties the couple
involved they were a married couple
childless married couple the only matter
evidence or whatever in the record
concerning their contention is contained
in their first amended original petition
that is that the woman would have
difficulty if she became pregnant in
carrying a child child burn further that
they were unprepared for Parenthood we
submit to the court that their cause of
action is strictly based upon conjecture
conjecture will they continue the
marriage will her help improve well the
they then be at some time in the future
prepared or unprepared for for
Parenthood there is no fear of
prosecution by Marigold if we accept all
contentions of these this married couple
we submit that they still do not come
under the prescribed conditions of class
versus Cohen angolan versus Twitter
we feel that the lower court properly
denied them standing has to the
unmarried pregnant female a unique
situation arises in is her action now
moot
of course if mood there is no case or
controversy pass action nothing it was a
class action surely you would I suppose
we can almost take judicial notice of
the fact that there are at any given
time unmarried pregnant females in the
state of Texas Western I would say that
the only thing that that upholds her of
her standing would be or eliminate the
Lucas issue would be whether or not this
is a class action on her part yes your
honor the record that came up to this
court contains the amended petition of
Jane roll
an unsigned alias affidavit and that is
all she alleges that she was pregnant on
April the 20th 1970 which is some 21
months ago now I think that it is it had
been recognized by the appellant counsel
that she is no longer pregnant this
Court has consistently held that the
time of determination of mootness is
when the hearings before the court that
is a case can become moot from the
hearing and the trial court until the
time it reaches this court we do not
feel appellant Safari contained in their
brief will substantiate their concur
contention that the case is not moot the
I might add this that I believe the law
to be that if there is a reasonable
possibility of reoccurrence of the
situation then the case would not be
moved now this is a deputy grant case
the other case our case is concerned
orders of the Interstate Commerce
Commission which the Court holds that
there is a possibility or a reasonable
possibility of continuation of those
orders and the the capability of
repetition it feels mainly with the
capability of repetition we think the
case of Jane Roe can be easily compared
to Paul versus Beals in that particular
case a group of voters instituted a
class action complaining of a Colorado
statute which prescribed a residency
requirement of six months they had at
the time lived in the state puts our
time of the election were living States
on for five months
the case came up through the lower
courts this
in the meantime Colorado revealed the
statute and established a two months
residency requirement the election was
held in the meantime the trial court
plaintiffs complained of the two months
residency requirement this Court held
the cause of action move even though it
was denominated as a class action
there's a big difference Colorado had
amended its statute in Texas has not
that is correct but the fact was that
you still had if it is what we want to
call it the the evil spell existing at
two months but it was the other statute
that had been the subject of the
litigation and that statute it but I say
her again feel it's not true here
there's no what we call white horse I'm
saying be in connection with the with
the class action aspect of this and I
say I have no authority to support this
proposition but it would appear that in
order for a class action to continue if
there be one to begin with is that one
plaintiff must remain or else an
intervener R or someone to be a
representative of the class so this is
the whole purpose of the class action
that were representative in for now the
position of the appellate Hallford how
do you suggestion if you're right how do
you what what procedure would you
suggest for any pregnant female in the
state of Texas ever to get any judicial
consideration of this constitutional
claim
Your Honor let me answer your question
with a statement I make and I do not
believe it can be done there are
situations in which of course of the
court knows no remedy is provided I
think she makes her choice prior to and
she becomes pregnant that is the time of
the choice it's like more or less it was
the first three or four years of her
life we don't remember anything
Oh but once the child is born a woman no
longer has a choice and I think
pregnancy meant for make that choice
that's what maybe she makes you charge
when she decides to live in Texas
now see the there's no restriction on
movies now Your Honor the appellant
Alford is under two indictments charged
with the offense of performing an
abortion there are no allegations in the
complaint of a felon all court are none
India's affidavit that there is any bad
faith prosecution bad faith the arrest
of harassment of him at all to bring him
within Dombrowski's special
circumstances we think the cases of
younger versus Harris and Sanders versus
Michael are controlling as to dr.
Harper's position
we also feel like the doctor hope we're
not reliable his patients rights to
bring him into federal court I think the
Tillerson versus Ullman case book will
be Authority for that proposition as the
matter of injunctive relief after a
court once grant declaratory relief I
would like this comment that it appears
the court can consider the propriety of
declaratory relief and consider the
propriety of injunctive relief that is
the court and divorce Mattoon and once
granting declaratory relief that are
cited in unconstitutional in its
discretion can determine whether or not
injunctive relief is proper and denied
is it so field now should this court as
I understand it and vzz all of the
parties feel that if this Court wants a
fire jurisdiction of the matter that the
parties would like the court to consider
all the constitutional issues
sustaining are you saying that the
denial of injunction was proper
because the declaratory judgment was
there no your honor they report
congratulatory relief costumes now and
denying dr. Billy I know but if they're
certainly if if the erroneously judgment
about the if the declared burger is
erroneous it was also right to deny
injunction under Mitchell characterize
your successor agency I think if they at
the court of course so didn't cross
appeal we have we could not to this
court your honor we have to go to Fifth
Circuit so we have but are you
attempting to sustain the denial of
injunction here on the grounds that you
declared your judgment in Hunter we are
we are asking the court testing the
courts to this that if the court gets
into the merits of injunctive relief
whether or not it was proper under the
circumstances that this court go forward
and continue the other are continuing
constitutional issues and make
determinations
you you in the fifth circuit because we
had good cross appeal from in the
territory judgments you can only first
feel fun and then jump grinders in
Ireland in Europe I suppose you could do
it if we bypass the court of appeals and
bring up for your appeal pending in the
succession you don't alright couldn't we
you're new you're here your opponent has
brought a direct appeal here because
your opponent you're denied an
injunction by the three-judge district
court yes you could not bring in a cross
appeal here because you won in the point
of view of successfully resisting the
injunction yes sir now that you're near
the appellee you're arguing that an
injunction should not have issued and
part of that argument is very
legitimately can be that on the merits
the court was wrong and that it
shouldn't have issued a declaratory
judgment or an injunction that's correct
and that is your position yes sir
now the proceedings in the Fifth Circuit
have been steak or a baby knife make
sense to me some of our prior cases are
the fourth motive unless we bypass the
the circuit and bring you appeal pending
they're here well your honor and I don't
be repetitious but a motion has been
filed in the field circuit to hold the
appeal in abeyance until a determination
either you did that you didn't file any
motion here asking us to bring your
appeal pending in the Fifth Circuit here
for decision with this view no we have
requested that in our in our of reply to
the jurisdiction and in our brief we
have presented it in that type of manner
Yano we feel that this court can and
should consider all issues and under the
Sterling Florida lawmen avocado growers
and the Carter cases which are cited in
the briefs of the parties what is Texas
interest in this session Oh
mr. justice the Thompson case which has
been cited the court Thompson versus
pages the Court of Criminal Appeals did
not decide the issue of privacy it was
not before the court or the right of
choice issue the state of the state
court the court of criminal appeals have
held that the state had a compelling
interest because of the protection of
fetal life thus of up to our protection
they recognized the humanistic of the
embryo or the fetus and they said we
have an interest in protecting of fetal
life whether or not that was the
original intent of the statute I have no
idea
and yet the yet Texas is not a peasant
I'm a woman who herself performs an
abortion honors huh that is correct your
honor and the matter has been brought to
my attention
why not punish for murder since you are
destroying what you are what has been
said to be a human being I don't know
except that I will say this as medical
science progresses maybe they all will
progress along with maybe at one time
it could be possible I suppose that you
could be paid whether or not that would
be constitutional or not well you're
dealing with the statute as it is though
there's no state fair that equates
abortion with murder or is there there
is none your honor except one of our
statutes that if the if the mother dies
that the doctor shall be guilty of
murder that's ordinary yes felony murder
I would say so Miss Jessica Texas does
it covers the entire period of crazy yes
it does that's justice
yes sir mr. Floyd is that Pompey I don't
find that complicates item akicha I
gather you said a toothpick and decided
recently Mr Justice best case we've got
a recent case you have a citation it is
not in the reporter system yet are you
going to provide this to the top here
I'll be happy to yes you provide the
court with copies of a ton of real this
is number 44 o 7 o CW Thompson versus
the state of Texas
the opinion was delivered on November
the 2nd 1971 I shall be happy to furnish
the court with this copy at the force on
the side and see Court of Criminal
Appeals yes you now and that's the case
mrs. Weddington Tomi is tending and we
found motion for rehearing yesterday now
there's one of you live up the prefer to
honored we'll distribute copies in that
in addition the Thompson case sided huge
gains in regard to vagueness and said
that is controlling the issue and as I
recall dr. Thompson raised the issue of
well how can you find me guilty of
murder
I mean of abortion yep you make no
determination that the fetus is alive at
the time I performed this in effect is
what he's saying he never admitted doing
it but he's saying it how can you proof
but of course the Texas Court answered
by saying it is presumed the fetus is
alive and an abortion is performed you
say they can answer to my brother
Marshalls question as to what is the
interest of the state in this
legislation there wouldn't want to be
this purpose what is its societal
purpose your answer lies I think relying
on your opinion of the most recent
opinion of the Court of Criminal Appeals
of Texas that it was the protection of
fetal life and that I think you also
said that was perhaps not its original
purpose well I'm not sure of that I was
it may be rather important in a
constitutional and a constitutional case
of this kind it becomes
quite vital sometimes too rather
precisely identify what the asserted
interest of the state is I think that
original purpose mr. justice and the a
present prevailing purpose may be the
same in this respect there have been
sophistication to this court in various
briefs from various groups and from
medical societies of different groups of
physicians and gynecologists or whatever
you may be these statistics or have not
shown me for instance for example that
abortion is safer than normal childbirth
they have not shown me that they're not
emotional problems that are very
important resulting from an abortion the
protection of the mother at one time may
still be the primary but because the
policy considerations unless just would
change may be fuzzy for the state
legislature to make a decision there's
my that's true policy questions or
through legislative and executive bodies
of the state and federal government but
we have here a constitutional question
and in refining and assessing that it's
important to know what the asserted
interest of the state is in the
enactment of this legislation I am and
this is just for month I speak
personalism I automate I would think
that even when this factor was first
passed there was some concern for the
unborn fetus unless in fact they was
1859 was the original statute this I
believe was around 1900
seven the fun fact hold back narrator in
the 19th century
yes before that there were no criminal
abortion laws in Texas women as poor no
no no no I think this is maybe set out
in some of the briefs on well in any
event mr. Boyd apart from your personal
attitude your quarters open only in
Canada statute Vietnam yes well I can't
quite square that most recent
pronouncement with the earlier decision
for the Texas Court that refer to the
mother is the victim can you well as I
say your honor the I don't think the
courts have come to the conclusion that
the unborn has full direct right right
not not not yet maybe they will I don't
know I just don't feel like the hell
with the present time first few weeks
for you sir in the first few weeks of
pregnancy or at any time mr. Gossett we
make no distinction in earth science
fiction where there's life there are men
we say there is life from the moment of
impregnation and you have any scientific
data to support that
well we begin mr. justice in our brief
with the development of the human embryo
carrying it through to the development
of the fetus from about seven to nine
days after conception over those six
days we don't know what the statute was
always like to one that I don't miss
justice there unanswerable questions in
this appeal I
oppressive this is an artless statement
on my part I withdraw the question
thank you or when does this phone come
into the the unborn if a person believes
in a soul I don't know I assume the
appellant now are operating under the
Ninth Amendment rights there are
allegations of First Amendment rights
being violated however I feel no there's
no merit this factor does not establish
any religion nor does it prohibit anyone
from practicing or being a part of any
religious group
I see no merit and their contingent they
could possibly be under freedom of
speech or press fact there's been some
articles recently in this city's
newspaper yesterday Francis the other
constitutional rights that the appellant
speaks on I think are expressed in two
manner the individual or marital right
of privacy and secondly or or the right
to choose whether or not to abort a
child now if if the those are out of the
case is American privacy is out of the
case but the as it may neither
individual nor marital privacy has been
held to be absolutely we have legal
search and seizures we have the
possession of illegal drugs the practice
of polygamy
other matters a current I do not believe
what cops cannot refuse to give their
child some form of education as far as
the freedom over one's body is concerned
this is not absolute the use of illicit
drugs the indecent exposure legislation
and as mr. mr. Goldberg stated in law in
the Griswold case that adultery and
fornication are constitutional beyond
doubt our Constitution really laws
against the law against inner
consciousness be there is nothing in the
United States Constitution
concerning birth contraception or
abortion now the appellee does not
disagree with the appellant statements
that they woman has a choice but as we
have previously mentioned we feel that
this choice is left up if it's the
woman's prior to the time that she
becomes pregnant this is the time of the
choice now this was brought out in
DeRozan versus Louisiana State Board of
medical examination for examiner's case
and in party versus Edwards which are
lower court opinions and my
understanding is that that party versus
Edward has been adopted in this Court
has been yes your honor I'm not positive
but I think it has been Texas doesn't
grant any exception case of rape woman
that pregnancy resulted from rape either
statutory or otherwise does it there is
nothing in our statute about that now
before seeing such a woman wouldn't had
a choice was she oh the procedure and
I'm I'm telling the court something is
outside the record but I understand the
easing procedure when a woman is brought
in acted rape is you try to stop
whatever it occurred immediately by the
proper procedure in a in the hospital
immediately strengthen Mary she reports
it illegal but no there is nothing much
now as I previously inform the court the
statistics what are the people who
prepare the statistics and the different
statistics are are not in conformity in
connection with the medical aspects of
the portion that is whether or not his
statement there are some statistics that
will say it here a statistic to say it's
not they have eight has been provided to
this court becoming law in the
legislative history of abortion and that
the the morality of abortion has been
injected in various cases and by various
groups we think these matters the
matters of policy which should be
properly addressed by the state
legislature we think that the
consideration should be given to the
unborn and in some instances a
consideration should be given for the
father if he would be objected to
abortion thank you your honor
unless you have some correction you wish
tonight versus whether I would only like
to draw it at the court the tension at
page 130 of the record the notice of
appeal by defendants state of Texas from
the judgment of the district court to
the Supreme Court of the United States
they had filed an appeal in this Court
thank you mrs. Weddington thank you by
the case is submitted